cette façon de transformer ses
faiblesses en forces que vous avez eu
depuis depuis toujours ça ça existe
c'est l'héritage de ta mère et de ton
père ça c'est que tu leur bar se lancer
sur un truc très pointue de courant de
quoi on peut se vanter certainement pas
de nos malheureux dont sur l'a23 dont
chabat il fait des films il a fait
didier cas remarquable il va pas arriver
avec la clope en disant je suis le roi
de la piste pour écraser vous y voilà
il ya un grand producteur il ya eu du
talent j'ai mis mon énergie j'étais
heureux il peut pas ramener à son ego
l'efficacité de son fils chez ces gens
là
[Musique]
va pas là
on centre
[Musique]
alors
mais les gens ils ont une image james
bond
ça a pris chan qu'on arrive à temps pour
changer james bond de become de 2 sec 6
10 alors les gens quand ils ont une
image fixe et sur quelqu'un il reste sur
la bible ou le coran
oui comme les religions bon on va pas en
parler mais je veux dire que qu' il faut
il faut un peu avec ces images c'est
normal
allez tout fait mais qu'est ce que vous
apprenez météo
la voir faire ça à la raison tu connais
pas les dossiers pouvoir en parler je
voudrais que vous connaissiez sur le
fond c'est vrai je vais le côté bobo le
côté gauche caviar j'y mets les
quartiers mais c'est pas une question
d'y aller c'est facile d'y aller mais
aussi le dossier tape à l'oeil
condé
la règle
eddy cue
je
une
[Applaudissements]
fragile
[Musique]
c'est fait
à
c'était le
[Musique]
ce
les arts
deminor
[Musique]
pour
ou pas
en
[Musique]
les
il faut dire majesté que toujours pour
le public français que vous n'êtes pas
un chef d'état comme les autres vous
êtes à la fois le chef spirituel et le
chef temporel du royaume du maroc d'une
part vous êtes l'héritier d'une dynastie
qui règne ici dans ce pays depuis trois
cent trente ans et d'autre part vous
êtes descendants du prophète et
commandeur des croyants
'cela signifie que vous êtes investi
d'une double mission veiller au respect
de l'islam et veiller au respect de la
constitution que vous avez vous même
donné à ce pays en vertu de cette
constitution
votre personne et sacrée et inviolable
et quiconque s'attaque qu'à votre
majesté comme est un sacrilège et
doivent expier son crime
on est arrivé
dans l'est
jarre 2
du ciel g
on tombe nez à nez
et
[Musique]
river susan où on sort et entend chanter
m
d
[Musique]